Jason when you were starting out in this
business what attitudes did you have
that were wrong
in terms of how the industry worked or
how to conduct yourself
in a meeting
[Music]
you know there's a saying that youth is
wasted on the young
I think what that saying means is that
we especially when we come out of film
school or school we
we just have this inflated sense of who
we are of how brilliant we are
that is the number one killer of careers
that I think that there is and just
having this over inflated sense of what
you can do
um
and I definitely suffered from that you
know because I
we all
who do this dreamed the big dream you
know we all watched that movie there was
probably a movie that you saw when you
were young and you were like
I can do that and we are and it's
probably true that's the thing
and then we just
start to build this framework of who we
are as people and then you actually get
into the world and start to try to work
and nobody looks at you like that
especially because well what have you
done you're just you're 20. you know uh
that really was um
was a blow uh
having a more of an ego than I deserved
if that makes sense you know
I think
I never and one of the things that
really
tripped me up for years and it still has
Ripple effects to this day is that I
didn't understand the importance of a
mentor
how much time that would have saved me
if I had just found someone to tell me
what to do because I had no idea we're
just stumbling around in the dark
uh
like how do you get the first job on set
who no one told me how to do that so
years had spent trying to figure out
even how to get an internship like my
God it's so hard so being humble enough
to just say
please give me some advice because I'm
I'm just want to learn
you know that kind of thing so those are
both probably fall under the humility
umbrella as far as the things that I did
wrong
um
I also think that there is a
that's the best way to say this
putting too much importance on
oh this I'm going to direct this two
minute short or whatever and putting so
much importance on it that you end up it
it ends up breaking under the pressure
like just
getting so wound up and so full of
anxiety over this one little opportunity
that you have that you end up locking
out all of the creativity you become
Vision locked into something that isn't
working you know that kind of thing
can really kill you
um
yeah uh because you want it so bad
yes and you're so you because you want
it so bad and because you
want to do it right
and boy I had to eat there is a real
pressure to the fear of making a mistake
um
and that is something I wish that I
could have understood a lot earlier is
that it's is if I wish someone would
have come to me and said it's all right
to mess up sometimes you know if you
look at some of the greatest moments in
cinematic history they were generally
mistakes you know or improv lines from
an actor or some sort of something
didn't go quite right and that's the
thing that's on the film because it just
had this real magical to it
when you're putting so much pressure on
making it absolutely perfect like you
and Afraid of the mistake you just kill
all your creativity that's such a
dangerous spot to be
um
I wish someone would have told me that
and I think
one of the thing I've noticed from
filmmakers who are very successful
is they have this very simple work ethic
that no one taught me that I wish I had
known
and that is like for example I I know a
couple screenwriters and they're I
they're
their work ethic is almost identical
they have a set time they get up every
day
and they
do their morning routine whatever it is
brush your teeth work out whatever
turn off their phones and for a couple
of hours block they right right and
write and write and write and write
up to the end of that little block of
time whatever they said usually it's at
least an hour or more
they take a break they take their lunch
they turn their phone back on they check
their Facebook and whatever
and then they turn it off again and they
write and they write and they write and
they write and they write and then they
cut it off and now they're free to relax
I I don't think I've ever even heard of
that done in any kind of filmmaking
class no one ever said to me like you
need to be
super disciplined and guarded with your
time
to make sure that you are honing
practicing working on your craft for set
hours every single day I didn't do that
man a long time long time years so
and those years they slip in they slip
by and suddenly it's a decade and you
just
aren't getting better you're stagnating
you're circling things right so I wish
someone would have mentioned that
early on because it would have also
really helped this is how people when
they break through at Young ages it's
because they've been more disciplined
about that kind of thing I'm convinced
of that where you see them come out of
the gate it's like dang how did this guy
get so good at 25. probably because they
were more disciplined
that very focused on
their craft that means being all alone
probably working on a script studying
reading without looking at their phones
and all of that kind of stuff
but when you're young
and you're thinking about dating or
whatever it is the distractions of life
it's it really will get in the way of
of your progress it'll just make it take
a lot longer
um I knew someone who didn't have a cell
phone when they first came out because
they had such
pressure on them to be accountable for
certain people that they wanted their
time in the car to be uninterrupted and
everyone would go why doesn't this
person have a cell phone and the person
would say that's my time
when I'm driving you know this is before
you know driving on you know with that
this was this is early on when before it
was this taboo as it is now in dangerous
but they were just like no that's my
time
and and that's what I'm thinking that's
where I'm doing things I need to do for
for my day and I don't want to be
disturbed
I think that's super vital you know it's
really interesting to me because this is
something that I've fought for in a nice
and simultaneously struggle with is this
idea of I'm going to take from 8 AM to
10 am and I'm going to work my craft
oftentimes for me that's writing
something but
the minute I do that the minute I
hit do not disturb my phone
and start hitting keys
my eyes drift over to that phone and I
want to see if anyone's messaged me it
is unbelievable that's called resistance
and it is a sneaky little bastard like
it
uh it's it's I don't know where I think
it comes from a lot of places for a lot
of people like fear of success whatever
you want to call it but it is Sinister
um
the
self-discipline that it takes to
actually go no I'm going to take this
phone I'm gonna put it in the other room
and I'm going to focus I'm going to turn
off my email turn off the messages on my
laptop turn off social media and I'm
going to focus on my craft for this too
straight over I actually got an
hourglass
that has a one hour
um timer on it I just flip it over and
I'll watch the sand go through it and
force myself to do it but every day it's
a struggle every single day that
resistance thing wants to fight you
um
but consistently the people I know who
have broken through did that and they
did that for years where and what's
crazy is
going back to what I said at the
beginning they create an enormous volume
of work because they're so dedicated if
you're finding yourself where you're
working all day long on whatever it is
that you're working on it's probably
some sort of day job that you don't love
and then you sit down to write a
screenplay that night for like 30
minutes while you're checking Facebook
you're you're just gonna take
you're just extending it out you're just
like you're gonna take 30 years to
actually get a meeting at that rate
um
yeah so
I think it's important to pay attention
to that resistance
because it looks like different things
to different people
Listen to Some People for People
Pleasers they have the people pleasing
disease and they want to be able to be
there for individuals you know they want
to be
present for friends and family but um
there can be demands so yeah yeah
this business this business is
I found that there is this intense
amount of anxiety attached to this
industry I think there's a lot of that
attached to life in general
this is not just me talking but if you
look at
societies worldwide
um
and the amount of people who feel
anxiety depression and those kinds of
things there is so many people taking
antidepressants so many people dealing
with this that they find traces of it in
the drinking water
and we've seen that I mean it's very
well known in La there's so many people
on Prozac or whatever that
um it's secreted and it ends up
you know that's why we have to have
filters on all our sinks because it's
all in there
well what's going on why is there so
many people so anxious and so stressed
out and so depressed I think that that
that's already there
and then it's exponentially harder in
our own industry and I think that that
comes from
and I hate this part of our industry
this comes from this place where there's
there's definitely a looking down the
nose at certain kinds of projects so
like if you I'll give you a perfect
example I was years ago I was looking at
joining the DGA
and my bread and butter oftentimes is
doing commercial corporate stuff and a
lot of that's non-union but that pays it
keeps the lights on keeps keeps me
working and it's it's actually great it
can be really great fun work and
fulfilling work
um
I asked them
so if I go Union can I still do
non-union work and they're like well
it's probably not a good idea
I'm like man I don't know if it's a good
idea for me to join at this point
because I can't just stop working what
am I gonna do go bag groceries until I
get a union job and they said to me
when you decide to take your career
seriously then you go ahead and come on
and sign up with us that right there is
exactly what I'm talking about it's this
little bit of arrogance with these
projects over here are legit
Marvel movie whatever you you know
high-end music video Marvel whatever you
you have these little category of movies
you know movies I've heard of or a TV
show that I've heard of
these are the legit ones everything else
over here if you're
making a wedding video or a whatever
like those aren't legit those aren't
considered and you're and when people
ask you that anxiety-induced question
what are you working on and the only
thing you're working on is a Colgate
commercial it's this flood of anxiety
that comes up it's everyone I know
struggles with it they struggle with it
especially when they're not working
you know when you haven't when you're
going to that event or even to a
friend's house because you know that the
question is inevitably coming what are
you working on and if you haven't been
working
what are you going to say like it is so
oh it just it just fuels us all and even
people I know who work a lot struggle
with the same thing
and I've spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what that is and how to how
to work with it and I do think there are
ways to fight it
um
I think the number one thing is
changing your relationship to anxiety
because when we experience it when it
crops up
we see it as a negative right it doesn't
feel comfortable
uh
there is a method in that I've heard
that I practiced through meditation
called noting and that means
when you feel the negative feeling or I
shouldn't say negative the feeling of
anxiety comes up to take one second and
step back from it and go okay
I'm experiencing anxiety is this
positive or negative anxiety
positive because there is positive
anxiety positive anxiety would be like I
got this big pitch meeting tomorrow at
HBO
or you know my film's in the contest I
hope I win that's positive that's cool
like I'm about to screen something oh my
hope my friends like it
that's exciting right that's a good kind
of anxiety and when you're experiencing
it and you're taking a second to look at
it and go oh well of course I'm on edge
because
my film's about to scream this is that's
a good that's okay and it's okay to feel
that there's also negative anxiety you
know like why Won't Anyone hire me you
know things like that
now when you note
these feelings it's I think really vital
to not judge it it you are not trying to
change it you are just recognizing it
I'm feeling anxious because rent is due
and I haven't been working okay well you
know what that's a rational fear that is
you know of course who wouldn't feel
anxious there's something about just
giving yourself a little permission in
some of those cases to just be okay with
it okay yeah this is a real threat you
know I need a place to live or whatever
because you don't want to get into the
Trap of being anxious because you're
anxious because that just does this
right so noting like just recognizing it
and then changing your relationship to
what it is
you can also uh take a look at it and is
this a thinking or feeling
kind of you know thinking would be rent
is due
you know this is a fact it's due on the
first and I don't have it that's a fact
feeling is
man every time it gets cloudy and rainy
I just feel down like that's a feeling
so again you're not changing it you're
just changing your relationship to it
when it rears its ugly head and going oh
it's a it's a negative feeling and it's
just a feeling
okay
well you know what I like hot chocolate
I'm gonna go get one of those and just
recognize it for what it is I'm not
going to try to change it I'm just going
to be okay with it I think that's a
that's a huge huge first step of dealing
with it
um
the second thing I would say is that
you really need to pay attention to the
people that you hang around with because
um you know they say misery loves
company and what that means is
when you get into a whiny mood like
finding other people to whine with
there's a lot of power in that and it
all it does is it it just feeds on
itself it becomes the Sloop and you can
end up becoming more angry and more
frustrated
I would say
challenge yourself to to be around
people who are relentlessly optimistic
or try to change your group's mindset to
hey you know I know we're frustrated
that we haven't been working but
what if we just made something ourselves
you know in fuel some hope into this
group that you're in if you can't change
your group right
or find a different group I think that's
super super important
um
the third thing I would say that I think
this has been a big one for me is that
um they say that the number one way to
fight feelings of anxiety is to find a
community
anxiety loves it when you're alone
you know depressed people when people
commit suicide they're not in groups
they're by themselves
there's reason for that you know
one of the best ways is if you're
surrounded by people who especially in
an optimistic positive
environment and I would say
that
this group
shouldn't be filmmakers
somewhere else
now I think and it's even better if it's
active like something physical but it
can be
kickball league or knitting or martial
arts or ballroom dance or horseback
riding just some sort of community
regular Community activity where you are
plugged into a bigger family of people
that's not filmmaking related is so
incredibly powerful
um
I personally I found Jiu Jitsu that was
my Big it really helped me a lot and
because in Jiu Jitsu I took it for
self-defense
um
they say that judges is one of the best
martial arts for self-defense uh because
in street fights things generally go to
the ground
and when you're on the ground how do you
deal with someone on top of you trying
to choke you
so I started getting into that and
the thing that's here's what happens
in my own Journey
I'll be anxious about something you know
that anxiety rears its head ah why
didn't I get that job or whatever
I won't want to go
it's one of my buddies from class will
go dude bro you coming
yeah I'll be there I go to class I'm
feeling I'm sitting in the car in the
parking lot ah I should go home and work
on that script or whatever no I'm the
class is starting in two minutes I'll go
in I go in
the minute I hit the mat
and so some kid is on my back trying to
actively choke me guess what I'm not
thinking about anymore
but never call me back I'm not thinking
about
the thing that's due tomorrow I'm
thinking about not getting choked by
this animal that's behind me you know
that is and when I'm done and it's a not
only is it an amazing physical sport
like you are exhausted by the end but
it's a huge endorphin dump you're just
like foom and you're around a whole
community of people who are learning a
skill getting better focusing on
something else they're making their
lives better these are people they all
have their own interesting and Rich
lives you are out of that artist
Community for just a second and you're
just enjoying some great social time in
another group I come back from that and
I am super charged when it comes back oh
oftentimes I'm on my way home like I
know what to say to that guy to get him
to call me back yes that's what I'm
gonna you know it's I'm usually on a
huge Euphoria high at the end of it
community community is so important like
I would highly recommend and I know that
the first step to doing that it's always
hard like to they say in Jiu Jitsu the
hardest belt to get is the white belt
because it's forcing yourself out of the
house into this straight group of
strangers for the first time but man
please
go out and get that done
um
and finally I would say when you if you
find yourself dealing with it there is a
lot of comfort in the fact that if you
are to to make sure that you are working
on your craft
continuing to make progress every day
there is a lot of comfort when
you get to the end of a year and realize
you wrote three screenplays that year
you know that's
that feels really good or you took a
whole writing class and graduated or
whatever it is like that if you are not
continually like getting better and
practicing and feeling yourself improved
you know that feels really good that
that can also because you'll know at the
end of the day
at five o'clock when you log off and you
decide to stop put writing aside for a
minute you can go play video games in
peace because you put in the work that
feels nice you can relax because you
know you did your work for the day that
that's a really satisfying
feeling
did you ever need to use any of the
moves in Jiu Jitsu in real life in real
life
uh let me think you know well
interesting story so
in my own journey I had some very
aggressive fathers so my both were
bullish both had a lot of street fights
so as a kid I grew up feeling utterly
powerless
this really carried over in a career by
the way like as I would approach people
that I was intimidated by like that
inner feeling of powerlessness was
really strong and so
when I went into Jiu-Jitsu I was
absolutely terrified like to
I was essentially finding My Own
Strength
uh
I was taking class for about a year
and a lot of the at least the school
that I attend is all about self-defense
it's just someone on the street comes up
to you and does this
you know here's some things you can do
at least to keep yourself safe
anytime I'd ever been in an aggressive
situation
it looked like something was about
standing in a bus stop in some
aggressive
was going to come up to me I'm
absolutely terrified and and wish I
could run away
right before the very first day of
shooting the abandoned my last feature
I hear a crash downstairs in the house
that we're staying in
three o'clock in the morning
I get up out of bed I'm totally drowsy
my dog is freaking out
I walk downstairs and there's a guy
standing in the kitchen
now
it was the weirdest most surreal thing
because
I was I was still just a very new
practitioner of Jiu Jitsu I didn't you
know I'm no I'm no badass
but it was the first time in my life
where I'm faced within a potential
aggressive person and I felt peace
because
the way the guy the guy was standing in
the kitchen leaning on the counter kind
of hunched I thought he was going to
rush me
um
but I pray in practice saying what
happens when someone rushes you in class
for a year so
I just in that moment I just looked at
him and I thought okay well if he rushes
me that's okay
I know how to deal with this I can at
least keep him from getting to anyone
else in the house while they call the
police or whatever
we can get this handled so
in the end it turns out he was drunk and
he found himself in the wrong house now
I didn't know this at the in that first
half a second when I saw him in the
kitchen you know for a couple of minutes
there it was real Touch and Go
prior to that I probably would have
grabbed the knife or
freaked out or whatever but
it really did in a very positive way
change
um it was a great way to start shooting
the movie
you know uh to just have that calmness
you know in the face of that kind of
adversity was was really
was really great and it could be
inspiration for your next script I mean
how bizarre is that that someone
accidentally goes into the wrong house
but I guess
right we all look the same I don't know
when it comes to inspiration for that I
mean I have we'll say that when you
learn
some when you get involved with some
other sport or some other
skill you're increasing your skills in
some other way it really does fuel ideas
like
you know if you're whatever horseback
riding class you're gonna be on that
horseback riding you're going to be
riding that horse you're gonna be
thinking man wouldn't it be cool to
write a story about someone on a horse
who's
it's going to happen it just will if
you're an artist you know that's that's
one of the advantages to doing that but
yeah
glad everything was okay yeah oh yeah